quantum mechanics is famously tricky
right what have we got going on here
okay so yeah you're right quantum
mechanics is is notorious for being a
very counterintuitive theory of physics
but it nevertheless is arguably the most
successful theory that humankind has
ever had in terms of its predictive
abilities but it still it still
confounds us with with the idea that you
know a single particle can be both here
and here simultaneously well that two
particles can be sort of inextricably
linked no matter how far apart they
separated such that doing something to
one instantaneously affects the other
our sort of Holy Grail if you like is is
the realization of a quantum computer so
that's a a that's a computer that
harnesses both this superposition of a
single thing being in two places or two
states at once as well as that
entanglement phenomenon and it harnesses
those things to be exponentially more
powerful for particular tasks in the
computing these computers are as I say
exponentially more powerful so for for
particular tasks and a quite a spectrum
of tasks and that means that you have a
capability to process information that
we could never otherwise imagine there's
no snow conventional supercomputer that
we could ever build that would be able
to tackle these tasks we're going back
into the age of 30 years time is why I
got this juillet an honor of mighty
mcfly um what does this mean 230 asst
time has it changed the way we live the
challenges that the world faces in the
future we're going to need dozens of
wonder materials for one of the better
name and it's going to be essential for
example that that single materials
before multiple functions so that they
you know harvesting energy as well as
providing the structure to a vehicle or
a building and we know for sure that
we're not able to UM design those
materials from from the first principle
without without a quantum computer
essentially